here's the race for the Democratic
presidential nomination entering a
crucial phase and what does it mean for
the future of the party both in America
and in the rest of the Western world
hello I'm John Prado and the u.s. editor
at The Economist and I'm the host of our
new checks and balance podcast on
American politics for the latest episode
I was joined by Charlotte Howard our New
York bureau chief and by John phasma and
our Washington correspondent to talk
about why it is that both parties in
America seem to have lost control of
their nominating processes with Donald
Trump performing something like hostile
takeover at the Republican Party in 2016
and Bernie Sanders doing something
similar to the Democrats in 2020 hope
you enjoy the episode Bernie Sanders
makes a big show of running against the
Democratic establishment doesn't he and
Harry Reid as a former Senate Majority
Leader is about as establishment in some
senses as it gets
but when Sanders says he's running
against the establishment is he running
against people like Harry Reid or what
is the Democratic establishment in in
2020 really anyway almost scenes when
Bernie Sanders attacks it to me like
it's a bit of a kind of Mirage I don't
what is the Democratic establishment I
have no idea I mean it's in you have you
have people who sort of used to be very
much part of the Democratic
establishment so from rahm emanuel to
the clinton's etc but rahm emanuel who
of course got his career started in the
clinton administration then went on to
be a congressman then served in Barack
Obama's White House before becoming
Chicago mayor he you cannot imagine
anyone sort of more part of the
traditional machine than he is and he
has been out making this point that the
Democratic electorate is not looking for
revolution there are lots of Democrats
who won and 2018 who helped to turn the
house blue who won in moderate districts
these are not firebrand
Sanders acolytes but the thing is it
does anyone really care what Ron Manuel
is saying you know I mean I really doubt
that the people who are coming to the
polls for Bernie I have read Rahm
Emmanuel's op-eds or be if they did
would care about it whatsoever and so I
think that there's there are people who
are in the establishment who are kind of
ringing the alarm bells the question is
whether
will make any difference so John Faceman
is the Democratic Party establishment
losing its mojo is it having another
1972 moment do you think I mean it
certainly looks like it doesn't it
you can talk to I have talked to no
shortage of freshmen Democrats of sort
of establishment Democrats with centrist
Democrats who are really panicked and
worried and they're all about to do
something and when you ask what is it
you're gonna do there's no real firm
answer I mean they they they Bernie
Sanders has just attracted more votes
than any other candidate has so far and
unless that changes he's going to be the
nominee whatever anybody thinks to it
you saw the development after McGovern's
loss of the Democratic Leadership
Council the DL C which has since no more
but it had a pretty impressive run of it
through the 90s helping to move the
Democratic Party to the center and
particularly during the during the
Clinton era and there was this book that
came out in 2008 called the party
decides and the and the thesis of that
was essentially that party endorsements
the the party's method of helping to
endorse specific candidates was the best
predictor of delegate winning that of
course just as completely looks obsolete
in this day and age it looked up it
looked somewhat obsolete in 2016
certainly in 2020 there's this feeling
that the people who were who sought
incremental change including Bill
Clinton and including Barack Obama
sought the vote of people who had low
incomes and African Americans but didn't
really do enough to change America to
help them they were too quick to
compromise they tried to seek deals with
Republicans that didn't bear fruit and
there was a disillusionment with that an
entire idea and so I don't think it's
surprising that the DLC is no more or
that you see this surge of support for
Sanders but it is worth pointing out of
course I mean if you added up the votes
of all of the moderates they would
exceed the support of senator Sanders
but nevertheless he has been able to as
a single candidate capture the
imagination and support of voters in a
way that no other single Democratic
it has Charlotte you heard in that clip
of Bernie Sanders and Hillary Clinton
debating in the last cycle in 2016 him
going after Hillary Clinton's ties to
Wall Street and there is that Wall
Street democratic party Nexus which I
guess senator Sanders has right in his
crosshairs and that he considers to be
the establishment right I'm positioned
here in New York and I have been having
conversations with different people who
are involved in New York Democratic
politics and in national politics
through their donations and there is
this sense of frustration I mean there
for many people they admire the policies
of Mike Bloomberg but Mike Bloomberg's
pitches you know I'm a good manager and
speaking with someone who said basically
you know he thinks that's gonna win him
votes is he insane that wins the support
of no one except that people were in the
Business Roundtable of course being the
organization of more than 150 CEOs and
so I think that there's this sense of
frustration among establishment
Democrats who make up a big share of
Democratic party giving giving that
there isn't a strong enough candidate to
really coalesce behind and and push
forward do you think that establishment
Democrats especially those who are in
business will come off the sidelines if
Sanders is Nam is the nominee do you
think they rally behind him do you think
they donate him you think a set up super
PACs where do they keep the money in the
pockets I think it really varies by
donor there was one person was speaking
with it was who's absolutely not a
Bernie person but is all in for Bernie
in the election if he becomes the
nominee and the reason for that is that
they see his policies as as poor they're
not the policies that they would choose
but Trump is operating a different plane
because of his attacks on the
institution of the presidency and he's
on a different plane in in moral terms
they see Sanders as not someone who's
gonna put children in cages one of the
things that I find really interesting
thinking about the collapse of
centralized party authority over a few
decades is how embarrassed essentially
the party establishment is to try and
exercise its authority I mean if you
look at the debate that took place
in South Carolina on Tuesday night in
the Democratic primary you had two
people on that stage in Bernie Sanders
who only joined the Democratic Party who
so he could run for its nomination and
Tom Steyer who's never held office for
the Democratic Party yet there they are
on stage and you know running as
Democratic primary candidates the party
could easily write rules saying you know
that's not okay you know you can only be
on that stage if you're a you know
recent of or current holder of office
for the Democratic Party and you have to
have been a member of the party for the
past five years or something that would
instantly kind of exclude some of the
insurgent candidates but there's a sense
of kind of awkwardness about that that
you know undemocratic for the party to
behave in such a way and therefore and
there's a Lexington column in this
week's Economist squarely on this which
is really good I vouch people to go and
read it there for both parties have
really made their party's wide open for
insurgent candidates who can come from
the outside is Donald Trump dead in 2016
as Bernie Sanders is doing in 2020 and
and capture the nomination it's a very
odd situation it is and I think the only
way you get over it is for one of those
insurgents to lose I think had Trump
lost in 2016 you would have found the
party taking that I forget what it's
called the autopsy that said they need
to sort of become more open to non-white
voters much more seriously
I think if Sanders loses in 2020 you
will see the party become much more
serious about trying to prevent those
insurgents candidacies again the problem
is Trump won and has sort of turned the
Republican Party into a very trumpets
party if Sanders wins I don't know what
his effect will be on the Democratic
Party but it will set the same precedent
that the party is essentially a vehicle
for individual candidates and their
ambitions rather than having the
organizational an intermediary function
that it's always had I'm gonna put both
of you on the spot here we're talking
just a couple of days before Super
Tuesday when we're on the next podcast I
expect we'll spend a few minutes
digesting the results do you think
Bernie Sanders will be unstoppable after
Super Tuesday or do you think there's
still a chance that one of the moderate
candidates might be able to catch him I
think that it would have to require
politicians to do what they are not
naturally suited to do which is
knowledge that their vanity needs to be
set aside and they need to act quickly
to throw all their weight behind one
moderate and so you'd have to let's say
that Bloomberg doesn't perform well in
Super Tuesday for instance he needs to
immediately take all of his cash
pour it behind someone else Chlo Bashar
I think has had an impressive
performance and different debates but
the the run that she's had to date
suggests that she's not going to be the
person who's he so you know there's
evidence already of people frankly who
should drop out and then after Tuesday
that evidence will be more compelling
and so it's really a question of acting
very quickly to put both resources and
their own political bases behind
whichever moderate is most successful
yeah I think if the field I think you're
absolutely right I think that the field
stays fractured he's uncatchable he
maybe uncatchable anyway if he wins by
enough in California and pulls out a win
in Texas I mean that's a lot of
Delegates and at that point the field
will inevitably winnow after Super
Tuesday but he will have already
accumulated a massive delegate lead and
whoever it is who's emerges as that as
the moderate from the field will be
playing catch-up and really has to run
the table in the rest of the States
which is gonna be tough since we
recorded this episode South Carolina has
voted in the Democratic primary the
result that wasn't a surprise in one
sense Joe Biden won we've been ahead in
the polls the whole way through his
campaign had long described South
Carolina as his firewall state of
insurance policy against him doing
poorly in the early states what was a
bit of surprise was the scale of the
victory
and that changes the dynamics of the
race a bit going into Super Tuesday if
Joe Biden can continue some of that
momentum he can turn this into a two
horse race if he can't and Bernie
Sanders wins handsomely in Texas and in
California the two biggest states up on
Super Tuesday then the conversation will
all be about where the Sanders can win
the nomination outright before the
convention in July and Milwaukee or
whether the Democrats end up with
tested convention so we'll be talking
about that a little bit on the next
episode thanks for watching if you'd
like to hear more episodes of our checks
and balance podcast then click the link
opposite there's also a link there to
subscribe to our checks and balance
newsletter that will arrive in your
inbox every Friday with the selection of
stories from The Economist on American
politics some other good stuff in there
too to keep up-to-date with economist
films don't forget to subscribe